During the Q4, our earnings improved despite some macro headwinds.
...including wide fluctuation of foreign exchange rates,...
...the sharp decline in oil prices and financial crisis in Greece and Russia.
The total revenue increased by approximately 11% compared to Q3...
...as overall business performance improved.
We fully expect the business environment in 2015 to be as challenging as that of 2014.
We still face global macroeconomic uncertainties due to economic recession in Eurozone,...
...financial risks in emerging countries from collapse of oil prices...
...and possible increase in key interest rates in the United States.
Also, from business perspectives, we expect intensifying product and price competitions...
...as well as increasing level of difficulty for developing new technologies.
We shipped in Q4 total handsets of 95 million units with about 11 million tablets.
As for smartphones, product mix has improved...
...with the increased series of high-end smartphones...
...driven by the global expansion of our latest fresh model, the Galaxy Note 4.
By regions, our sales improved mainly in North America and Southeast Asia.
Regarding tablets, shipments increased Q-on-Q...
...due to higher sales of Galaxy Tab 4 series.
Market demand for smartphones is expected to continue increasing from last year...
...due to global expansion of LTE services and growth in emerging markets...
...including China and India.
The tablet market is also expected to increase, mainly driven by mid to low-end products.
With our competitive new product lineup, we will actively increase our smartphone sales.
In the first quarter, we will introduce Galaxy A5 and Galaxy A3 globally,...
...which were first launched in China last December.